pleased to have here on the program for
the very first time the man who plays
john walker the c.i.a agent who has been
revealed as the new captain america
falcon the falcon and the winter soldier
uh as the pair who came together in the
final moments of avengers end game have
teamed up
on a new disney plus series we talked
about it with anthony mackey just a
couple of weeks ago and now the man who
is the new captain america
wyatt russell here on the rich eisen
show how are you wyatt
hey rich have you gone i am doing great
i am doing well i am doing well thanks
for
for being on the program today um
so uh how did you get involved in this
this i i i according according to a lot
of people i think i took out
chris evans legs and then yes and then
that's that's how i'm captain america
now
i i i just auditioned and went in and
they called me and said hey we think
that you should do
this that you read for this part
in a marvel show and uh i was like okay
they don't really tell you what you're
doing
and i went in and i read and they said
okay great
you think you're great and you're the
guy and then i was
like okay who's who's who am i playing
and they tell you who you're playing and
and then you have a couple meetings and
i decided that it would be a good idea
yes
here i am yes and now here you are and i
appreciate you you calling in and
uh you know talking about this it's it's
a it's a hot show
uh my kids dig it on uh disney plus and
we've been watching we've been watching
it together and we've been we've been
eager to see something since the
mandalorian was over and we didn't
you know we didn't hit up a wanda vision
we're going to do that at some point as
well but you know
we had anthony mackie on on the show the
other day he's just a great dude man
i just he's he's the nicest guy in the
world he's such a good dude
he's so funny and he's uh he's
it's all it's always fun when you find
another actor who's in
into sports as much as he is like he's a
real he's a sports fan
and uh it's not every day that you go
into set and people want to talk about
you know what happened in the nationals
game last night you know
well i mean you want to talk about what
happened what did he talk about a hot
take i mean he came on and he was saying
that uh
that sean payton uh would rather have
lost with the taysom hill than one with
jameis winston in a playoff game or lost
with drew brees
then win with jameis winston in a
playoff game that's a red hot tape
that's him just being
he's he's just being contrary there's no
way he thinks that he's the he's a huge
norlin saints fan
here's the other thing about mackie that
i love yes and also
everybody just needs to know the guy is
the king
of the of of of the smack talk
in terms of in terms of bringing up
something
just just to stir a hornet's nest and
i'm
i'm i'm willing to bet that if you got
him in private there'd be no way he'd
really honestly think that well we got
him in public
we got him in public he said that on on
on this show for everyone to hear and
for it to be tweeted about and
so what what do you think that's true
there's no way that's true
no well i mean that was his way of
saying that he thought that
brees wasn't as as useful for the saints
to
beat the bucks as jameis winston was you
know and
and um i don't right that's a tough one
for me to swallow i'll be very honest
with you but he did say that so
how how did he stir it up with you what
do you do because is hockey your
favorite sport or
what what what what would you say is
your favorite honestly no to play
to play uh yeah hockey was
obviously that was my life right um
to watch live there's nothing better
than a hockey game in my opinion
it's just great you it going to take
somebody who's never been to a hockey
game
uh to a hockey game is is a really fun
thing to do just because
compared to all the other sports for
even for a non-sports fan
there's always something going on
there's fights there's people bleeding
all over the ice and then
the goal happens and everyone goes nuts
it's just a good live sport
on but on tv it's reversed
it's the worst sports to watch on you
can't i can barely get through a game i
watch i'm a kings fan and i'll watch the
kings but
everything else is like impossible until
you get to playoff time
and then for me playoff hockey there's
nothing like it it's like
the there you go these guys it's hard to
explain
if you're not a hockey player didn't
grow up idolizing
being a hockey player but i think
there's something genetically
with the type of person who wants to get
up at 4 30 in the morning
when you're seven and freeze your behind
off
and your parents are miserable in a rank
and that's what you
choose to do that's like that's what you
choose to do for fun
and and that and so when you get to the
opportunity ultimate opportunity of
winning a stanley cup those guys
it's when when the stanley cup is
presented to me there's not there's no
other trophy like it
there's no there's there's no more
here's shed it's just
it's it's the hardest thing to do it's
so hard
so let's let's let's unpack that a
little bit here wyatt russell so
um you are a former professional ice
hockey player
correct like what what how high how how
high a level did you get to before your
injury professional hockey in europe so
i played in germany and holland for
uh a coup a couple years i had a blast
doing it
i played uh college hockey uh camp
talbot was my
goalie partner okay um and uh
so i played along the way with a bunch
of buddies who are still playing and
i have a lot of fun watching um
cam having a good season this year for
minnesota
um and uh and so that that was
you know my path i got injured in
college a lot it
tore my groin um i woke up one day as a
sophomore and
looked at my future in hockey and said
well i want to go have an experience a
lot of guys do
live in europe make a little bit of
money and just
you know and end it over there
realizing that you know the dream is
dead and i need to move on with my life
but i still can't let go
so i need to i need to play three or
four more years just to have somebody
tell me i got injured you know basically
the year that i was kind of
done and saying like i think i don't
want to do this anymore i got injured um
i say that now but it is like a drug
where all of a sudden next year it's
like norway wants to give you
six cents to go play over there do you
want to go do that yeah yeah
exactly anything but live life no but so
so what's the best what's the best night
you ever had between the pipes
what russell what do you got for me
what's the best night best night that i
ever had
in between the pipes i actually have a
couple but one
one was a 4-3 loss in penticton on my
first junior egg
where the hell is that if you don't mind
me asking in that manner where's that
and
is uh in british columbia over the bchl
um and i just had a great game it was
just one of those games when
where you're doing everything right
i i we lost three to two in overtime but
it was
it was a game that made me go that made
other people go to oh you can play in
this league
playing pc junior all right and it just
i it was great i made a save in overtime
where the or the visiting fans
cheered and it was one of those just one
of those i'd probably be at 47 shots or
something like that it was just it was a
loss but
at the end of the game i just it was
like okay it was it was a great
showing and the other game was we were
down three nothing in a
in a series in the in the when i was
playing during my first year junior
and uh it was do or die
and i had a 40 shot shutout one-nothing
win
from coquitlam and it was it was i mean
i came back to win this series we came
back from three nothing we ended up we
actually ended up
finishing second in canada that year and
uh
we lost in double overtime to
saskatchewan
that was a heartbreaking loss but if any
of the richmond sockeyes are listening
to now
bring a tear to anybody's eye a sockeye
there are a couple great ones so who's
the most famous person who's ever scored
on you then why
which is ah
a year in coquitlam i played against him
in maple ridge so it's probably
lucha all right so who who's the most
famous person you ever cross checked out
of the crease
what what you ever slashed in the crease
what do you got for me
that's that's i honestly i can't i i
don't know if anybody that was standing
in front of
a net that i played in yes was uh was
was
made it made it anywhere important
[Laughter]
all right so and then what's it like to
be a a hockey kid someone you you who
loves hockey so much
to see uh your father play her brooks
at the you were 18 years old when
miracle came out what the hell was that
like to see
i mean that iconic hockey film and
there's your dad playing her brooks what
the hell was that like
funny that was interesting it's
interesting because that
until a miracle came out the the story
of
the 1980 olympic team was was sort of
this mythical lore
story it wasn't something that was
widely known amongst my age group
it was it was known it was cool if you
were a hockey player but the world had
kind of
forgot about it it had drifted into the
history books a little bit
and that movie brought it back and made
it tangible and palpable for people who
hadn't
experienced it and for me
it wasn't this legendary game it was
only legendary and so far as other
people's memories
knew about it we didn't have the it
didn't there was no instagram or twitter
or whatever
the hell we'd use now to get our
information
back then so it was only youtube and
dvds
um and so when that movie came out it
popularized it
and funny interesting thing during that
movie
they would shoot after we'd play
sometimes
we'd play in abbotsford or a couple
other arenas yeah
and we'd play the game and my team would
play and
they'd finish and then and then the crew
would come in and
they would shoot my dad would come in
and use the ice and they'd shoot after
our game
okay there's probably five or six times
where we'd play the crew would come and
watch
and then the the they'd take over the
ice after the games two of our
players from our team actually left
because you know they made they were
making 40 grand or whatever they made
some real money during that
during that time and they left the team
and then wanted to come back after
the movie was over to join the playoff
run and it was like yeah
i think you made your decision i think
you're done
did you not coming back did your dad
ever make you skate to your drop after a
game did that ever happen
screaming again he wasn't that he wasn't
now he wasn't he wasn't that bad of a
pit
there's a there's a big difference
between a parent who makes you do that
yeah
if your parents making you do that i
don't know but i don't have good great
hopes for your relationship with your
father
why russell here on the rich eisen show
i got a couple photographs from your
from your past here and then we'll
circle back to your present
um some a couple photographs the first
one i believe is from the
1993 stanley cup uh last game in the los
angeles uh in los angeles i believe
that's you next to your mom
goldie hawn who's next to the reagans um
nancy and ronald um wyatt do you
remember this
moment in 1993 you were just seven do
you remember sitting with the reagan and
your mom
up rink's side i'd i i
i remember one day my dad
saying uh look at that
you can remember that guy he was an easy
important person and
i don't know if it was then or whatever
but i do remember seeing this sort of
older man who
i honestly i think he was sort of losing
his mind at that point
um and not not maybe not i don't know if
i don't know how much he was remembering
at that point because i do remember him
kind of
me going that guy is important like
doesn't seem like he knows where he is
and and uh so i i do remember feeling
that way about
ronald reagan where he was like he's
definitely had seven i could tell he's
like i
don't think that person's all the way
there right now
unfortunately that's the memory that's
the memory on ice watching gretzky go at
it you know with melrose and everything
like that
on the bench it looks like gorbachev is
actually behind the reagans doesn't that
look like crystal
it's really weird the whole thing is
really weird gorbachev and he was
such a nice guy and now and now we've
got one from uh
the i believe last stanley cup you with
your contemporaries i believe with uh
your brother
oliver and uh joshua jackson and uh
and chloe uh grace moretz and there you
are
larry i think you're up looks like
somebody just scored from
from the kings so you are you remember
uh-huh that wasn't over that was the
game
they understand the cup i think they won
the stanley cup that game it was alec
martinez i think scored the game-winning
goal am i right if someone did you have
a fact checker
there on a computer that was to win
listen talk
did chris are you are you is that that
is yeah martinez scored the game-winning
goal that
what clinched the cop that year i think
that's your couple moment that
took that was it and and and i had mixed
feelings because cam was the backup goal
he had an amazing season that year
uh as the back up because lunch went
down for a while
and cam carried the team for like i
wanted 35 games
a lot of games a lot of games for a
backup and he got them there
or helped get them there so i did have i
truly had mixed feelings because it
would have been amazing to see
a friend of mine left the stanley cup
but unfortunately it didn't happen
i bet but it looks like you're having a
good time amongst friends and um
you know and i i can't wait to get to
back to all of these fandom moments for
you and for hockey
uh wyatt russell a couple minutes left
here on the rich eisen show
so okay uh what what can you tell us
about this series and where it is going
and and maybe to tell some people who
might be in your grill
to calm down a little bit uh why what do
you got for me
i don't want to tell anybody to calm
down i'm i'm i'm happy with
however people feel about it it's great
i i could
i could care less i'm i'm happy that
people have found the show
um basically what's going on now
is that uh a new captain america has
picked up the mantle
we're in and we're anthony making
sebastian scams have falcon
and the winter soldier and bucky and
they
are uh trying to deal with this new
captain america john walker while
they're also trying to
fight a band of rebels
uh called the flag smashers which is
like a punk
band to like kids they're like bad kids
with bad attitudes and a punk band and
super powers
and they are uh gonna you know
take over the world um and we all gotta
try and stop them but we all have to
work together
and i'm not great at working together
with people uh people don't love also
that i'm
not chris evans which i totally
understand you know i hate that i'm not
chris evans i wish i was chris evans
and uh but that's not that's it's it's
not
you know look i don't want to get you in
any more craziness but it just
it is nuts that people have gotten upset
and
is it true you have you go tapped out of
social media because of this
why that people are obsessed no somebody
asked me that i've never had
i've done i don't have social media okay
no i don't i don't i've never had it
somebody you know what's so interesting
about the world we're in now
is that you have these virtual worlds
people live in
like i don't live there right i proudly
happily live in
reality land and and
but there's a world that i think i exist
as an alternate being in an alternate
universe
that people really dislike i kind of
don't mind it because it is
there is a representation of art aspect
to it where it's like
this person that doesn't exist or people
just despise and they
they unleash their hate and aggression
and all this stuff
i kind of don't mind it it's i don't
know it's virtual it's not real and i'm
i'm just hearing my house sitting around
doing nothing and
nobody recognizes me and it's great so
all of the all of the ire and hate and
whatever it is i'd say like it's okay
you can feel that way
i wouldn't you know go too far with it
and it's still like a movie it's a
it's fake it's a comic book and it's a
tv show
um you know it's not real uh but but
it's fun it's what it's supposed to do
that's your job i elicit a response from
people and they they tell me how they
feel
well i mean it's got to when it all said
and done though
i mean it's got to be so damn cool to
see yourself
in captain america gear i mean that is
that is like a
childhood dream for so many no people
it's not from honestly i know i don't
mean to sound flippant about it
it's great to be able to work with
people that i love working with it's
been fantastic it was a great experience
but i i didn't grow up
idolizing comic books i grew up
idolizing sports heroes like i just
didn't even know that comic books were a
thing i didn't none of my friends did
comic books i mean none of my friends
read
i didn't even know it was not a thing at
all zero
none and uh and so this
is totally new to me so i can't i only
found out about it probably like when
you know iron man came out i guess when
they started doing them like that they
were always just kind of like
mediocre attempts at trying to create
comic book movies and then iron man came
out and it was like oh wow these can be
great these can be awesome they're cool
they're
they can be good and then and then i
started getting on board but
honestly it was it was the you know
seeing the costume was oh great hey cool
i know what people hate me for no not at
all
you know you got your head screwed on
right it's a gig it's a hell of a gig
and and it's very popular and i'll just
look forward to seeing you in the dom
and akashic story one day and
then you'll be really excited yeah i
gotta work on my check axe
is that what it would be or is it the
luke robitaille story or patrick wah
story where am i going to type story
that would be a pretty
deep cut there would be like seven
people at the theater
i love luke
i look forward to seeing that in a
theater near you starring wyatt russell
you know i mean all right well i'll go
to you for the funding first
wyatt thanks for the call i hope this is
the first of many times let's uh let's
keep talking pucks and what's going on
in your life and i'll have you back
anytime so thanks for the call really
appreciate it thanks a lot
you guys wyatt russell right here on the
rich eisen show the falcon
and the winter soldier check things out
on disney plus
new episodes drop every single week and
the latest episode coming out on friday
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here